grab a drink with Barnes and I because a
new episode of Silo means new Clues
theories and having to deal with my
terrible dad jokes for those of you new
to these videos this is not a
traditional recap of the episode rather
a deep dive into all the Mysteries Clues
and where they could go as always I've
left timestamps below to all the topics
I'll be covering keep in mind I have not
read the book so there won't be any book
spoilers and any trailer sleuthing I'll
leave till the end of the video now grab
your Silo suits it's time for us to go
outside this episode focused a lot on
Juliet's past specifically her
relationship with her father Dr Nichols
who we met last episode but I can't help
but get the feeling there's way more to
this relationship than meets the eye all
we know so far is that both her brother
and mother died when she was 13 years
old in episode 2 it was hinted that the
mother may have committed suicide after
the loss of her son Jacob who we see
here suffering from what might be in
illness notice that we never find out
exactly how he got into this situation
when we open on him we're right in the
middle of the action and Jacob's lips
are purple suggesting he's been without
oxygen for some time we learned the
mother's name is Hannah which also
happens to be the title for episode 8.
so I'm expecting some more backstory
with her later on Hannah also seems to
be leading her son's recovery giving out
orders to her husband and Juliet even
though her husband is a doctor which
leads me to believe she's a doctor too
or someone who's been through this
situation with Jacob many times before
later in the episode we Flash Forward to
after the deaths of Hannah and Jacob and
Juliet blames her father for the way
things are now this is the way things
are now
I don't know about you guys but that
made me think he was somehow involved in
one or both of their deaths not in a
malicious way but perhaps did something
that could have made things worse this
is part of what Spurs Juliet's
fascination with fixing things she was
told early on that the broken chair
couldn't be fixed but defiantly proves
her father wrong how can Juliet believe
her father couldn't fix her mother and
brother when she fixed something he said
wasn't fixable there's also this
exchange I'm happy I really don't have
time to think about Mama Jacob
or me Juliet's silence here is deafening
something else definitely had to have
gone on in my episode 3 video I
highlighted all the theories of who
poisoned mayor Ruth with the poisoned
water bottle being my number one I also
suggested that perhaps Ruth wasn't the
intended target and marn seems to think
so too his theory is that while he and
the mayor were spending the night in the
mids someone poisoned their bottles and
if it hadn't been for a leak in his he'd
be dead too after all Ruth is beloved by
all while Mars has numerous people who
hold grudges against him after years
enforcing the law now it's still
possible this could be a misdirect and
that mayor Ruth was the intended target
due to her insistence that Juliet be the
next Sheriff but the dialogue here was
really pushing for that theory to be
dispelled you're saying she wasn't the
target plus someone attacks marns at the
end of the episode suggesting this
person is here to finish the job but
I'll get more into this guy in another
section so who poisoned mayor Ruth or or
should I say who intended to poison Mars
my money is still on someone in the
judicial but we honestly weren't given
too many Clues with Juliet taking over
holston's apartment we finally get to
see what he hid there from episode 1
tied to a fishing line are the files on
George Wilkins files which Sandy told
her judicial didn't have any record of I
zoomed in and analyzed all the papers
but nothing of note came from my
investigation so they're probably saving
what Clues are in these files for Julia
to discover next episode I also noticed
that it doesn't appear that the hard
drive is in this bag I mean I could be
wrong I'm basing this solely on the way
she plops down the bag after taking the
files out the end of the episode sees an
unwelcome visitor attack a drunk Deputy
marns from the end credits using process
of elimination and IMDb we can see this
belongs to a character named Douglas
Trumbull someone we haven't met yet
there's a lot that's really weird about
this scene if this guy is here to
assassinate Mars why not just do it as
soon as he came into the room with the
shotgun it's implied that his shotgun
was already taken since when Martin goes
searching for it it's not in his gun
cabinet Trumbull already has it in his
possession and even when he has it
pointed at marns he doesn't shoot and
let's say he didn't have a shotgun at
all he has no weapon no knife nothing
now is this just a case of the show
putting in a fight scene because it
would be exciting who knows but it ends
with the assailant holding barns at
gunpoint what I'm wondering is if this
guy is the person who was supposed to
kill marns in the first place or if this
is someone hired by Sims to offmahon so
that Juliet is kicked off the force
earlier in the episodes Sims says that
if Mars and the new inter-mayor Bernard
agree they can have Juliet fired leaving
the decision for a new sheriff up to
judge Meadows we all know judge Meadows
wants her own Yes Man in that spot but
what Sims doesn't know is that Mars has
already made a deal with Juliet if he
helps her find who killed George she'll
help him find who killed Ruth so
Martin's tell Sims that Juliet quote
deserves more time to screw up and just
a quick reminder before we get into more
stuff if you like these videos consider
liking and subscribing it really helps
the channel out this episode also sees
the introduction of Lucas he's actually
in two scenes the first story has no
lines but you can see him transfixed on
the screen the second scene he
introduces himself to Juliet and refers
to her name being from a play Romeo and
Juliet and that it may have been written
by a rebel honestly this scene doesn't
Advance the plot at all and you could
take it out entirely without it
affecting the story so my guess is that
this is setting up something much bigger
to come why is he so interested in
what's on that screen and it looks as
though he's drawing or taking notes too
check out my trailer section for more
info about him I don't know about you
guys but something just rubbed me the
wrong way with how Sandy treated Juliet
I mean I get that Juliet was thrust into
this new position taking the place of
someone who is much beloved but she just
had an instant hate on for Juliet makes
me think there's something deeper here
we also have Martha Walker uncovering
something from the camcorder which
Juliet gave her last episode she has it
hooked up to her computer suggesting she
can either pull data or actual video
from it we did see in episode 1 in the
Jane Carmody file that computers in The
Silo can play video so my guess is that
this combined with George's files will
be vital in Juliet's pursuit of the
truth two things that were brought up
this episode but we learned nothing new
of is holston's badge which says the
word truth also the title of this
episode I wouldn't be surprised if this
is the last we hear of it as its main
purpose seems to have been to get Julia
to take the job regardless she still
wants to keep the badge when Sandy says
she could take it Juliet also finds
holston's note double the flowers in
front of the mirror but in regards to
this nothing really new is brought to
light as to what it could mean now we
get to the part where we check out the
teaser and trailer to see if there are
any new Clues I won't be going over
every shot of course only the ones that
pertain to new information picked up
this episode here we can see the
intramayor Bernard officiating a funeral
of two people we know that mayor Ruth is
dead and the way we left Mars wasn't
looking good Mars isn't visible in the
wide shot either so maybe this is Ruth
and marnes here's Lucas again and it
looks like he's helping Juliet notice
something on the screen is she holding
one of his drawings or notes but it
looks like Lucas may be of some help
uncovering the mystery my first thought
is that this scene has something to do
with the position of the Stars since
they're so bright here but who knows
with this shot knowing these are
Juliet's tattoos she does indeed get her
hands on that hard drive and Juliet is
here with her crying father so it looks
as though we may get more information
regarding these two and some
reconciliation between them now I turn
it over to you I want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstory YT until
next time remember hey someone's always
got a theory about why a machine breaks
I deal with facts